la tendance sur 7 jours glissants est
aujourd'hui à plus de 70 me le cas le
taux d'incidents incidence nationale est
ainsi supérieur à 700 soit au plus haut
depuis le début de la crise face à la
flambée des contaminations en france le
gouvernement a annoncé de nouvelles
mesures ce lundi 27 décembre plusieurs
seront effectives pour trois semaines
boire debout sera interdite dans les
bars et les restaurants pour les
rassemblements la jauge sera limitée à
2000 personnes en intérieur 5000 en
extérieur les concerts debout seront
également interdits un nouveau coup dur
pour le monde du spectacle
respecte le bas sanitaire soit ça les
distances le gel et puis la bombe a
certes reçu il ya l'aspect artistique
c'est pas évident pour un groupe non pas
d'avoir des gens qui sont assis alors
qu'ils ont un petit devenu et l'autre
c'est bas qu'on va pouvoir faire plaisir
à moins de monde vers une reprise
fragile
cédric gary et quitter le public re
venait et l'a à nouveau c'est difficile
pour nous c'est vrai c'est également le
grand retour du télétravail il est de
nouveau rendu obligatoire quand il est
possible trois jours minimum par semaine
le télétravail il ne
s'impose pas il se prépare et il
s'organise en fonction des situations et
des contraintes de chaque entreprise il
aurait fallu que l'entretien que le
gouvernement se rapproche de nous pour
qu'on puisse d'abord faire un retour
d'expérience et leur dire ce qui marche
qui marchent pas et surtout surtout leur
dire de la façon dont il faut agir pour
limiter au maximum le contact
dans le milieu professionnel parmi les
mesures non retenu la saint sylvestre se
fera son couvre-feu même constat pour la
rentrée des classes qui ne sera pas
décaler les élèves retrouveront bien les
salles de cours le 3 janvier prochain
c'est important pour les enfants de
venir à l'école maintenant ce qui serait
au moins tout aussi important c'est de
considérer qu' on est dans un mode pour
être poli dégradée dans l'enseignement
mais c'est pas le point de vue de
monsieur blanc caire qui continuent à
vouloir imposer des réformes à mettre en
place la veille pour le lendemain
qui que les écoles n'ont absolument plus
la capacité de de suivre étant donné
déjà la très grande difficulté assurer
la présence de tous les enfants et de
tous les personnels enfin autre annonce
majeure à retenir le délai pour la dose
de rappel est réduit il passe à trois
mois après la dernière injection du
vaccin